the trial of derek chovin the officer
involved in the death of george floyd
is going on right now now i'm using my
words carefully i'm not saying the
officer who killed george floyd
or the officer involved involved in the
killing of george floyd i'm saying
he was there at the death and the
question is
did this police officer murder george
floyd
did he accidentally kill george floyd or
did george floyd
suffer a drug overdose did he resist
arrest
well we know he resisted arrest we know
he was on drugs we know that he asked to
be taken out of the car we know
all of those things just from video so
what was the cause of death
already the left thinks that this this
cop is going to get off you know if the
if there's justice the left
seems to think that the cop will get off
because they're they're preemptively
saying he there shouldn't even be a
trial
we we should just pay money to the
family of george floyd and the other
race hustlers who are trying to exploit
this situation
we we're bracing for riots we're bracing
but why
because you think he's going to get off
why do you think he's going to get off
well for instance
because george floyd's girlfriend
admitted on the stand yesterday
that george floyd had a very very bad
drug habit
and a drug habit that was so bad that he
did
overdose within two months of his death
which may or may not have been caused by
an overdose
we went to the hospital a couple times
in march okay
he was hospitalized and for a more
extended period of time in march right
yes that's the incident i'm talking
about okay
i went to go pick floyd up from his
house
that night i thought i was taking him to
work
he wasn't feeling good his stomach
really hurt he was doubled over in pain
just wasn't feeling well and he said he
had to go to the hospital so
i took him straight to the hospital
um we went to the er
and um they were checking him out
in the er and
it was getting late and i had to get
home to my son so i left
that friday night did you later learn
that that was
due to an overdose yes
[Music]
so it goes on
more and more evidence that george floyd
died of a drug overdose
i mean even just the report of the
toxicity in his blood he had
very very toxic levels of drugs in his
blood
this is i'd like to stake out a third
position here between
george floyd is the worst person in the
world and he got what he deserved
and this cop killed george floyd and you
know he needs to go to jail forever or
something like that
what if it's the case that george floyd
resisted arrest took a bunch of drugs
overdosed that this cop has been
wrongly maligned whatever happened in
the moment that he's
what people are accusing of doing he
didn't do and what if one can
sort of feel bad for george floyd
but george floyd robbed a pregnant woman
at gunpoint yeah he doesn't sound like a
good guy he does not
sound like a good guy at all but what if
one can feel
sort of bad for george floyd in that
the the drug addiction that he obviously
had
is just the clearest representation
of vice and sin
and broken human nature this guy
was obviously not totally in control of
what he did he's an addict i know that
in the modern liberal view
being able to pursue your base desires
is considered the definition of freedom
but it's not it's the opposite of
freedom it's licentiousness
and it compromises your free will and it
it compromises your ability
to control yourself and your desires and
it compromises your rational faculties
and that's a very sad thing it's why we
shouldn't
let druggies completely off the hook and
say well it's not your fault no it kind
of is your fault
you know maybe maybe it's a vicious
cycle maybe you had bad circumstances
and then you turned to drugs and then
you further impaired your will and then
you couldn't get out of it
maybe it's a bad cycle and you're
somewhat responsible but you've also
compromised your free will during that
what if that's the case if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
you